found over 200 digital murders and we've
just started looking never even heard of
digital murder night and vibe I think
we're looking at a new hack here Avery
we have a very fancy edgy villain in
Kelly Osbourne we got you connected to
the digital murders of 75 people
including the ex-husband of an FBI
deputy director no immunity deal for me
and we'll all be walking away from this
little powwow unhappy we will be unhappy
at home you will be unhappy and an
eight-by-ten jail so I play Stella who
is an Internet assessing it's really
been fun and educational because I don't
know what technology this at it at all
so she's I think definitely the most
diabolical villain that we've had smart
enough to commit the crime and also
smart enough to be away with it she's
the angel digital dad you never once
mentioned a partner no no I didn't
because I believe there's honor among
Steve we've had a couple of great
villains with which is really great
about Kelly's character is that she's a
silent killer the method to Stella's
madness is that she kills people
digitally she doesn't actually
physically murder anybody the passports
been canceled says here in Michaels is
dead and what she does is she gets near
you in your proximity with the
electronic device that can sort of
swooped up all of your information
remotely she deletes all digital trace
of a person's existence so she clears
bank accounts Boyd social security cards
all that kind of stuff and and files a
death certificate so essentially you are
a dead person and she does that for
higher so she can wipe any slate clean
consider this digital death 101 it all
starts when someone contacts her happy
and then hires them to commit murder
she's ruining their lives certainly but
not leaving a body count you can find
out anything about anyone understood if
you know how
still in SF whatever helps to sleep at
night I sleep just fine because i have
my rules no kids no cops everyone else
is fair game like I said I've an avid
kind of anything CSI you know sometimes
when we watch the episodes you can kind
of see where it's going this episode you
read don't know where it's going